i hope you're with your family
on super bowl it's super bowl sunday
guys
justice for haunt don't know what's
really all gonna come out today
just in case subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction is up super bowl
sunday meaning a lot of quick trailers
to cover a lot of quick thoughts to let
out into the universe
f9 i'm excited for this every time i see
that trailer i'm just like man it's
just bringing such a big smile to my
face let's get down to business
[Applause]
wow
the most glorious 30 seconds of my life
that is the most energy i've exuded all
day
it just brought it out of
that was insane whoa it just
goes sideways drifts through a
restaurant lands two people insane
he just cranks the wheel just when you
think it can't get more insane there's a
shot here that looks like it's straight
out of
tennis buildings falling oh you got this
this bike chase scene kind of looks like
a fast and furious version of the return
of the jedi
speeder by chase perfect you know what i
mean with the rumors that they could be
going to space and this one it could
it could be a tribute and i'm really
surprised that you know
invisible man came and came out last
year and they're already crossing it
over into the fast and furious universe
first video of the day it's all warm-up
jokes today guys give me a break
i can't see him and i didn't see him in
this trailer even though i'm sure he's
here
all right guys well f9 the saga
continues this is some
superhero crazy bonkers [ __ ] hit that
like button leave your thoughts down
below
check us out in a little bit
[Music]
you